supongamos que tengo una base de de un
sub espacio vectorial que tiene cada
vectores de uno de dos hasta de acá
entonces tengo esta base y supongamos
también que tengo un vector a y que yo
sé que a tiene ciertas coordenadas con
respecto a b conozco las coordenadas de
a respecto a b y estas coordenadas son
segundos 2
y como tengo acá vectores en la base
entonces voy a tener acá coordenadas
entonces este vector las coordenadas de
a continúan hasta una seca tengo acá
coeficientes y lo que significa esto de
acuerdo con nuestra definición de
coordenadas respecto a una base esto
significa que a
tiene una representación como
combinación lineal de elementos de la
base cuyos coeficientes son precisamente
los elementos del vector es decir se uno
por b 1 más de 2 por fe 2 y así hasta
seca
seca por beca entonces tengo esta
expresión para como una combinación
final otro modo de escribir exactamente
lo mismo otro modo de escribir esta
combinación lineal
es considerar una matriz cuyas columnas
son los miembros de mi base es decir
pensemos que tengo una matriz ce donde
los vectores columnas son simplemente b1
b2 así hasta de acá ahora sí supongo que
estos vectores son miembros de rn
entonces cada vector tiene n coordenadas
y esto es una matriz de l porque cada
columna es un vector de n entradas y
tengo k columnas así que ahí tengo esta
matriz y para volver a escribir esta
combinación lineal solo tengo que
considerar el producto de la matriz c
por el vector c1 c2
así hasta seca por el vector de
coordenadas de a con respecto a la base
b
el resultado de este producto es
precisamente el vector
el vector en coordenadas a estándar así
que estas dos expresiones son
exactamente la misma si toma el producto
de matrices obtengo segundo por b uno
más de dos por b2c
de 2 más de 3 x de 3 y así hasta seca
por beca y eso me debe dar a obtengo la
misma combinación lineal ahora bien si
escribo esto de otro modo puede decir
exactamente lo mismo pero lo voy a
escribir de otro modo voy a escribir sé
que es la matriz que tiene como columnas
a los vectores de mi base
por este vector que es el vector de las
coordenadas de a respecto a la base de
entonces ce por el vector de las
coordenadas d
respecto a la base de lo que nos da es
sencillamente a es decir la
representación de a en la base estándar
de rn y bien porque me tomé la molestia
de describir esto de tantos modos pues
es porque ahora tengo una fórmula
sencillita que me permite si me dan por
ejemplo las coordenadas de un vector en
términos de una base b puede encontrar
fácilmente cuánto vale el vector a cuál
es su representación en términos de la
base estándar
de rl simplemente tengo que multiplicar
por la matriz c que tiene como columnas
a los vectores de mi base y por el
contrario si lo que tengo es el vector
an
y yo sé que se puede representar como
una combinación lineal de los vectores
de la base o sea que están en su espacio
generado por esos vectores entonces
puedo hacer un sistema de ecuaciones y
puedo obtener las coordenadas de a en
términos de la base de así que esta
matriz
lo que nos permite es cambiar de la base
ve a la base estándar o viceversa
simplemente al multiplicar por ella así
que como esta matriz nos permite pasar
de una base a otra es completamente
natural llamarla la matriz de cambio de
base matriz de cambio de base a pesar de
que el nombre es muy rimbombante la
matriz en sí es muy sencilla simplemente
consiste en tomar los vectores de mi
base como las columnas de la matriz
bueno vamos a poner esto en práctica y
vamos a hacer un ejemplo voy a trabajar
con vectores en r3
voy a suponer que tengo un primer vector
b 1 que es igual
vector 1 2 3
y también voy a tener un vector b2 b2 b2
va a ser el 101
entonces digamos que tengo ve que es b1
b2 el conjunto es de 1 b 2
y como b1 b2 y les dejo de ejercicio que
verifiquen que b1 y b2 no son múltiplos
el uno del otro o sea son linealmente
independientes por lo tanto b es la base
de algún sub espacio vectorial así que
tomemos un vector que se que esté en el
sub espacio generado por b1 y b2 así que
le pueda asignar coordenadas con
respecto a esa base voy a decir que mi
vector
tiene coordenadas con respecto a b
y digamos que estas coordenadas son 7 y
menos 47 menos 4 y ahora la pregunta
natural es cómo puede representar a con
las coordenadas estándar con la base
estándar de r3 quien es el vector a vaya
pues podría simplemente decidir pues hay
siete veces por ver uno más menos cuatro
veces de dos y les daría el resultado
correcto pero vamos a usar la matriz de
cambio de base para que veamos cómo
funciona
nuestra matriz de cambio de base en este
caso tiene como columnas de uno y de dos
en otras palabras nuestra primera
columna es el primer vector de nuestra
base y la segunda columna es el segundo
vector de la base de acuerdo con lo que
hemos dicho si multiplico a la matriz de
cambio de base por el vector de
coordenadas debo recuperar el vector
original director de coordenadas es 7
menos 4 y lo que voy a obtener es la
representación de el vector a en las
coordenadas estándar noten que esto es
una matriz de 3 por 2 y esto es una
matriz de 2 por 1 así que voy a obtener
una matriz de 3 por 1 que tiene todo el
sentido del mundo porque estamos
trabajando con vectores en r3 así que a
pertenece a r3 y requiere tres
coordenadas para describir su posición
en términos de la base de estándar la
base estándar tr3 sólo tiene tres
vectores quizás esto resulte un poco
confuso a recibió dos coordenadas
respecto a la base p
porque estaba en el sub espacio generado
por v1 y v2
mejor hago un dibujo de lo que está
pasando supongamos que este es el sub
espacio generado por b1 y b2 con el
vector 0 en ese punto así que este es el
sub espacio generado por b1 y b2 o dicho
de otro modo
este es el sub espacio de r3 que tiene
por base a b
ahora bien imaginemos que ve uno se ve
algo así y que ve dos
bueno aclaró no estoy siguiendo los
números no se vayan con la finta esto no
está escala supongamos que ve dos se ve
algo así bien ahora como a esta en este
sub espacio vectorial se puede
representar como una combinación lineal
de b1 y b2 de hecho a es siete veces
cree uno
cuatro cinco seis siete veces ve uno
- cuatro veces de dos entonces uno
y 4 si lo trasladó para este punto uno
dos tres cuatro así que mi vector
está sobre este plano y se ve algo algo
así está completamente dentro del plano
amarillo algo que es importante es que
está dentro del psuv espacio vectorial
generado por b1 y b2 es más a es igual a
7 veces b1 menos 4 veces de 2 entonces
al decir que a es miembro de este sub
espacio vectorial solo requiere dos
coordenadas para determinar su posición
simplemente tengo que decir cómo me
muevo en dirección b 1 y cómo me muevo
en dirección de 2
ahora bien no debemos olvidar que este
plan no está contenido en r3 está metida
en el espacio entonces lo que quiero
encontrar ahora son las coordenadas del
vector a como miembro de r3 ya no como
miembro de este plan no únicamente muy
bien ahora usaré la fórmula para
encontrar las coordenadas de a con
respecto a la base estándar tr3 este
producto de matrices equivale a 7 por 1
más menos 4 por 1 que es 32 por 714 más
0 por menos cuatro que es 14 y luego 3
por 7 más uno por menos 43 % 21 menos
417 así que a es igual al vector
14 17 y esta es la representación de a
en coordenadas estándar supongamos que
ahora quiero hacer lo contrario
supongamos que ahora lo que me dan es un
vector de en coordenadas estándar de r3
supongamos que d es el vector 88 menos
62 y supongamos que yo ya sé que de está
en el sub espacio vectorial generado por
b1 y b2
donde veo 1 y 2 son los mismos que antes
así que de ésta en el generado de b1 y
b2 eso de por sí ya nos dice que de se
puede expresar como combinación lineal
de b1 y b2 o lo que es lo mismo que de
se puede representar con coordenadas con
respecto a la base b donde les recuerdo
que la base b es simplemente b1 y b2
ok ahora yo sé que si toma una matriz de
cambio de base con una matriz de cambio
base y la multiplicó por el vector que
tiene las coordenadas de d con respecto
a la base b o sea lo multiplicó por el
vector de coordenadas de respecto a la
base vea lo que obtengo es d en
coordenadas estándar así que yo sé que
dadas las coordenadas desde con respecto
a la base b puedo encontrar las
coordenadas de d en la base estándar en
este caso lo que tengo es las
coordenadas estándar desde y sé cuál es
mi matriz de cambio de base así que para
encontrar las coordenadas de d
con respecto a la base b tengo que
resolver este sistema
mi matriz de cambio el base de 9 11 20
y la tengo que multiplicar por el vector
de coordenadas de d con respecto a la
base b que es lo que estoy buscando lo
voy a poner aquí en amarillo ahora como
tengo dos miembros de la base de un
nivel 2
tengo dos coordenadas c1 c2 que son las
que estoy buscando además tienen que ser
dos porque el producto de esta matriz
por un vector como la matriz es de 3 por
2 tiene que ser por un vector de dos
dimensiones
y esto debe ser igual
y b es el vector 862
así que si encuentro a c1 y c2
automáticamente automáticamente
encuentro las coordenadas de d
con respecto a la base b
así que vamos a resolver este sistema de
ecuaciones
y para hacerlo voy a tomarme una matriz
aumentada que es como siempre resuelvo
los sistemas de ecuaciones
me tomo la matriz 1 1 2 0 3 1 que es
nuestra matriz de cambio de base y el
aumento con el vector de 8 menos 6 2
ahora voy a hacer operaciones
elementales en los renglones
para poder llevar esto a una matriz
escalonada
así que voy a tomar en este caso el
primer renglón se queda igual y cambió
mi segundo renglón por dos veces el
primero menos el segundo así que tengo
dos por uno menos 20 2 por 1 es 2 - 0 es
2 por 8 el 16 6 y el 10
y ahora voy a cambiar el tercer renglón
por tres veces el primero menos el
tercero
tres por uno es 3 - 13 03 por unos 312 y
luego 3 por 824 3 por 8 24 - 2
21 2
aquí ya me doy cuenta que cometió un
error porque lo que me dice el segundo
renglón y lo que me dice el tercer
renglón son cosas incompatibles así que
vamos a checar mis cuentas mi segundo
renglón era mi dos veces mi primer
renglón menos el segundo
así que tengo 2 - 2 que 0 2 por 1 2 - 0
esto 2 a 2 por 8 16 - menos seis es 22
allí estaba mi error se me olvidó un
signo
ahora lo que voy a hacer es
voy a cambiar mi tercer renglón por el
tercer renglón menos el segundo renglón
todo lo de arriba así que igual 11 8 02
22 y ahora el tercer renglón va a ser el
tercer renglón menos el segundo renglón
así que 000
ahora voy a dividir el segundo renglón
entre 2
esto hace que igual 118 y esto se
convierte en 0 1 11 luego el tercer
renglón es simplemente cero cero cero
ahora le voy a restar al primer renglón
el segundo el segundo se queda igual 01
11 y al primero le restó el segundo
1 - 0 1
1 - 10 y 8 menos 11 es menos 3 y este
renglón se queda igual con puros ceros
entonces ya tenemos esto en su forma
reducida
entonces puedo escribir esto como
la matriz 100 100 multiplicada por c1 y
c2 a c1 c2 es igual a menos 3 11 0
entonces si hago el producto de matrices
1 por 10 por cerdos f1 debe ser igual a
la primera entrada de mi vector de la
derecha que es menos 3
luego la segunda entrada sería cero por
segundo más uno por dos estados y debe
ser igual a la segunda entrada del lado
derecho que es 11
entonces nuestra solución a esta
ecuación es simplemente menos 311 o
dicho de otro modo las coordenadas de d
con respecto a la base b
son menos 311 déjenme lo noto aquí
abajito el vector de escrito en
coordenadas con respecto a la base d
es igual a menos 311
esto por definición quiere decir esto
quiere decir que b es igual a menos tres
veces de uno más once veces de dos y les
dejo esto como ejercicio que verifiquen
que esto es cierto así que la moraleja
del cuento es que la matriz de cambio de
base nos sirve para pasar de una
representación de un vector en
coordenadas respecto una base a la base
en la representación del vector en la
base estándar o si nos dan las
representaciones en la base standard con
un poco más de trabajo podemos obtener
las coordenadas con respecto a una base